de vous tenir informé de la situation
puisse avec plaisir que je le fais
aujourd'hui
premièrement sur la situation
épidémologie
j'aimerais remercier tout d'abord les
travailleurs de la santé qui ont
sacrifié
leur temps des fêtes qui continuent de
sacrifier leur temps des fêtes pour
soigner les Québécois dans des
circonstances on sait qu'ils sont pas
faciles mais je veux remercier aussi les
Québécois qui eux ont sacrifié beaucoup
de réunions de famille et d'amis pour
éviter d'étendre la contagion la
communauté qui est déjà très forte
mais malgré ça vous avez vu vous avez pu
contester la fulgurante hausse des cas
dans les deux dernières semaines et même
je vous dirai je pense qu'on s'en doute
un peu que ce n'est pas vraiment les le
vrai noms parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de code dans la réalité alors mais on ne
sait pas justement combien
mais ce qu'on essaie d'éviter par dessus
tout vous serez pas surpris que je vous
dis ça c'est le débordement du système
de santé comme à peu près partout en
Occident on est pris dans un étau où les
hospitalisations augmentent alors que de
plus en plus de soignants doivent
s'absenter autrement dit on a de plus en
plus de malades et de moins en moins de
monde pour les soigner
pour ce qui est des hospitalisations je
veux souligner qu'on a encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur les caractéristiques
du variant au micro-ondes on continue
d'échanger avec nos experts sur le sujet
mais il nous faut encore quelques jours
pour préciser les projections que l'on
vous fait habituellement de nos experts
en fait je vais résumer il y a trois
grandes inconnues que nous avons sur un
micro en ce moment
premièrement on n'a pas encore de
certitudes sur la sévérité de migrants
tout indique qu'il cause des symptômes
moins sévères que le delta mais jusqu'à
quel point est-ce que ça va permettre
par exemple de réduire les durées de
séjour on ne sait pas encore
deuxièmement on constate que la
situation en soins intensifs est
encourageante dans les anciennes vagues
on avait par exemple un cas de soins
intensifs pour cat hospitalisation
là au cours des derniers jours de la
dernière semaine on est plus à un cas de
soins intensifs pour 10 code
hospitalisation maintenant est-ce que
cette tendance là va se maintenir et
même s'accentuer je vous dirais que ce
serait une très bonne nouvelle parce que
les soins intensifs c'est très très
demandant ou exigeant en termes de
personnel sur notre réseau
et la troisième grande inconnue c'est la
cause des hospitalisations et ça c'est
important de le voir avec les
statistiques que vous voyez tous les
jours depuis quelques semaines toutes
les personnes qui se présentent à
l'hôpital sont testés et comme la
transmission est très forte dans la
communauté on a beaucoup de cas positifs
et là il faut qu'on arrive à départager
les hospitalisations qui sont dus à la
covid
de celles qui sont pour d'autres raisons
on doit le faire systématiquement pour
avoir un portrait qui est juste de la
situation et pour savoir ce qui nous
attend dans les prochaines semaines
en fait on espère avoir des réponses
assez trois points là et bien d'autres
dans des prochains jours mais on
pourrait avoir agir sans attendre et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on va faire
pour continuer de limiter donc pour
continuer de limiter les
hospitalisations on met en place
immédiatement deux nouvelles mesures
premièrement on va changer de paradigme
pour les travailleurs de la santé et je
vais l'expliquer en détail et
deuxièmement on va ajouter de nouveaux
groupes pour la troisième dose
maintenant c'est mon deuxième point
quels sont les nouvelles mesures qu'on
va annoncer pour le personnel de la
santé
j'ai rencontré avec mes collègues les
syndicats dans les derniers jours et
encore une fois ce matin avec non
seulement les syndicats du réseau de la
santé mais aussi les professionnels
comme les associations de médecins de
pharmaciens en fait on a mis tout le
monde ensemble pour faire le point
mettre en place ces nouvelles mesures en
fait je vous résumerai qu'on a un enjeu
de société et c'est la même chose un peu
partout dans le monde
la contagion par un micron elle est
tellement exponentielle qu'on doit
retirer énormément de personnels comme
j'ai expliqué et ça ça nous pose un
risque sur la capacité du réseau à
soigner les Québécois
ça nous impose d'effectuer un changement
de paradis qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que dans les vagues
précédentes qu'est-ce qu'on faisait on
identifiait et on retirait le plus vite
possible les employés qui étaient à
risque mais avec le niveau actuel de
vaccination puis on est chanceux on a
98% de notre personnel qui est vacciné
dans le réseau de la santé on peut faire
autrement lorsqu'on a le choix
et là en concertation avec la santé
publique avec les directions cliniques
du ministère de l'inespeare on a pris la
décision que sous certaines conditions
le personnel qui est positif pour
continuer de travailler selon une
priorité une liste de priorité mais
aussi une gestion des risques
et je rappelle que ce n'est pas
uniquement pour les travailleurs de la
santé on travaille aussi pour que cette
mesure s'applique à tous les
travailleurs essentiels pas uniquement
ceux de la santé si on veut que notre
société continue de fonctionner de façon
sécuritaire et les détails de ça
viendront dans les prochains jours
en fait je le résume si on avait le
personnel qu'il faut on n'aurait pas
besoin de poser ce geste mais là en ce
moment on doit prendre des mesures très
concrètes et très pratique c'est une
gestion de risques et une question de
balance des inconvénients
j'avais dit que je vous tiendrai informé
il y a quelques jours on parlait de 4000
travailleurs qui étaient absents hier
c'était environ 5000 et je pense que
dans les prochains jours c'est 10000
travailleurs qui seront absents pour la
pour raison de la covid alors dans les
circonstances vous comprendrez qu'on est
mieux faire travailler un employé qu'on
aurait retiré avant mais en autant qu'on
le fasse sous certaines conditions pour
éviter des bruits de service
vous garantis que ça va être du cas par
cas qui va être fait en fonction de
chacune des sacs des situations qui sont
propres à chaque région on le voit
partout dans le monde tous les réseaux
de santé sont confrontés au même
décision
rappelle on prend cette décision parce
qu'on a mieux faire ça que d'aller au
dernier niveau de délestage qui implique
de faire seulement les soins critiques
alors si on se met à faire plus de
délestage on risque d'avoir des domaines
des dommages pardon permanents pour les
usagers notre priorité ça reste toujours
la même c'est de soigner les Québécois
qui en ont besoin
je vais essayer de vous donner des
bonnes nouvelles aujourd'hui
troisièmement la vaccination de la
troisième dose
on a déjà maintenant avec la bonne
semaine qu'on a eu juste un petit peu
avant Noël on a maintenant un peu plus
qu'un million de 3e dose qui ont été
donnés et à compter de demain
on va élargir de nouveau groupe bon
premièrement sur les clientèles
prioritaires les groupes comprendre
rendez-vous c'est sûr que les
travailleurs de la santé du privé et
autres travailleurs de la santé comme
pour les soins palliatifs les
entreprises qui sont d'économie sociale
et d'aide à domicile le personnel qui
est en milieu scolaire les organismes
communautaires de la santé des services
sociaux que j'en profite pour pour
saluer la sécurité publique les
inspecteurs du MAPAQ et le personnel des
abattoirs pour la chaîne alimentaire
c'est très important
et je rappelle que la vaccination est
déjà ouverte pour les éducatrices les
premiers répondants et toute une série
de travailleurs je vous demande de vous
informer pour le détail
pour la population générale et c'est ce
que je crois qu'il est la bonne nouvelle
Daniel pourra vous donner des détails
tout à l'heure mais par la suite
ce sera au tour de la population
générale les 18 à 59 ans dès le 4
janvier c'est dans les prochains jours
on va ouvrir les rendez-vous par groupe
de 5 ans comme nous l'avons fait avant
ce qui nous amène jusqu'au 21 janvier et
on va publier comme nous le faisons
habituellement le calendrier de
vaccination pour ces groupes d'âge là
et je veux rappeler aussi pour les
groupes qui sont en cours des fois les
gens l'oublient mais je veux rappeler
que pour les 60 ans plus les personnes
avec des maladies chroniques les
travailleurs de la santé et les doubles
vaccinés d'AstraZeneca peuvent déjà
prendre un rendez-vous pour leur
troisième dose on va continuer
d'accélérer la troisième dose parce
qu'on veut en fait vacciner de deux à
trois millions de personnes par mois ce
qui nous amènerait en mars pour avoir
vacciné l'entièreté de la population
alors mais je le rappelle inquiétez-vous
pas si vous voulez prendre votre
rendez-vous et qu'il est plusieurs
semaines plus tard l'idée pour nous
c'est de prévoir les opérations et on va
rajouter des rendez-vous disponibles au
fur et à mesure qu'on aura la capacité
pour le faire
maintenant
je j'aimerais m'adresser encore une fois
au non vacciné et à leurs proches
vous devez savoir
que c'est beaucoup les noms vaccinés qui
se retrouvent aux soins intensifs et qui
luttent pour leur vie présentement et
même en survivant il y a souvent des
séquelles qui peuvent être graves et
durer pour le restant de vos jours
avec les statistiques des derniers jours
et avec la venue de migrants je veux
être très clair très très clair au cours
des prochains mois si la tendance se
maintient des derniers jours
et je parle au nom vaccinés ou bien vous
allez vous faire vacciner ou bien vous
allez faire la maladie et faire la
maladie quand vous êtes non vacciné
c'est de mettre une pression
inutile sur notre réseau de santé
je le rappelle il n'est jamais trop tard
pour se faire vacciner allez-y vous
pouvez aussi faire partie de la solution
alors en conclusion je vous jette je
voudrais que chacun d'entre nous pense
au travailleur de la santé qui sont au
front
nos infirmières nos médecins nous
préposés nos techniciens de laboratoire
nos unanothérapeutes les pharmacies et
j'en oublie je m'en excuse par respect
pour eux je vous implore de prendre les
mesures pour limiter la contagion
j'aimerais rappeler au Québécois que la
meilleure façon de ne pas attraper la
covid et donne pas la transmettre et
d'éviter des rassemblements et de
réduire nos contacts au minimum chacun a
sa responsabilité de limiter les
contacts surtout pour les personnes de
60 ans et plus qui n'ont pas encore
leurs trois doses pour ce qui est encore
plus dangereux pour eux
veut vous assurer
qu'on va continuer de suivre la
situation de près et on vous reviendra
avec des mesures supplémentaires si on a
besoin de le faire au fur et à mesure
que les experts auront des nouvelles
informations sur le micro d'ici là bon
courage tout le monde et je vous
remercie
tu continues
in dollars days morning to protein price
majors
au micro-ondes
of personal have to be wiendrun and risk
to the network qui passe
it for make Paradise shift une previews
and remove espace
merci Monsieur Dubé nous allons
maintenant débuter la période de
questions nous commencerons avec les
questions en français dans la salle et
nous poursuivrons avec les questions à
présent virtuel et nous finirons avec
les questions en anglais dans la salle
et par la suite en virtuel merci de
respecter une question et une sous
question par journaliste
micro 2 donc Sabrina rivet de nouveau
d'abord j'essaie de comprendre la mesure
pour le personnel des travers de la
santé vous nous dites qu'ils sont
complètement épuisés à bout de souffle
il manque de personnel de les faire
travailler avec la covid ça risque pas
de mettre les mettre encore plus à terre
si on avait le choix on le ferait pas et
dans toute gestion du risque d'un réseau
comme celui de la santé il faut trouver
l'équilibre
lorsqu'on a bien expliqué et puis votre
question est très à propos puis qu'on a
discuté avec les représentants syndicaux
dans les derniers jours on leur dit on a
deux choix des personnels existent en ce
moment il est pas là et on a deux choix
ou bien on force ceux qui sont là à
rester plus longtemps c'est ce que
permettent les fameuses arrêtées 007
qu'on essaie d'utiliser au minimum
où on demande aux gens de rester plus
longtemps alors on essaye de trouver le
meilleur équilibre mais comme je l'ai
répété ou représentant syndicaux dans
les derniers jours on a un enjeu qu'on
sait depuis longtemps ça nous prend du
personnel additionnel là les gens le
comprennent mieux que la première chose
à faire c'est d'aller chercher du
personnel mais en ce moment même une
situation tellement urgente et critique
à court terme qu'on essaye de prendre le
moindre des deux mots
et en sous question le CDC aux
États-Unis dit bon que les isolement
fait passer de 10 jours à 5 jours pour
les personnes asymptomatiques est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous regardez
tout à fait donc on commence la première
étape parce que c'est quand même des
discussions je pourrais passer la parole
à docteur aruda mais effectivement on va
peut-être falloir aller plus loin puis
je pense qu'on comprend très bien ce que
le CDC vous Etats-Unis
on peut voir que le problème est partout
tout le monde actuellement c'est impact
cette haute transmission va rendre des
travailleurs de la santé malade certains
symptomatiques certains peut
symptomatiques certains qui peuvent
encore travailler mais on y va avec une
gestion du risque qui a été discutée
notamment avec toutes les directions
cliniques du ministère pour vérifier il
y a-t-il d'autres alternatives avant de
se rendre à ça mais force de constater
que si d'ici en peu de temps le 23 et
demi des choses et le lendemain ajoute
la question du 5 jours c'est parce que
la problématique est réelle et elle
n'est pas seulement Québec
de Radio-Canada j'aimerais avoir
quelques précisions au niveau des
hospitalisations parce que d'après les
données
d'après les données du ministère de la
Santé le nombre de corps à porter en
date du 26 décembre n'est pas le même
que l'homme de corps a porté par
l'unescq on parle de 146 pour le
ministère
239 pour l'infq alors j'aimerais savoir
précisément combien de nouvelles
admissions hospitalières ont été
rapportées et en combien de jours est-ce
que c'est pour le 26 et le 27 en fait le
25 et 26 décembre 239 expliquez-moi ça
on va garder ça très simple le bon
chiffre qu'on a publié ce matin c'est le
bon chiffre c'est 146 hospitalisation
toutes sortes d'ajustements d'Inès PQ
fait mais je pense que depuis le début
qu'on publie nos chefs c'est les bons
chiffres alors aujourd'hui les
hospitalisations c'est 146
si une chose il y a peut-être moins de
hospitalisation c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure puis c'est ça
que je veux que les gens comprennent
c'est que ça on essaie de trouver les
bonnes nouvelles où il y en a et je le
répète en ce moment lorsque quelqu'un
arrive à l'hôpital je vais donner cet
exemple une dame qui vient pour
accoucher
elle peut venir pour accoucher sans même
savoir que la cabine en ce moment elle a
dans les statistiques covid parce que vu
qu'elle est testée en entrant on dit que
les covid alors à ce moment c'est ça
qu'on a demandé à une institut c'est pas
d'avoir plus de cas mais on en a
probablement moins on estime en ce
moment de baser sur les travaux parce
que avec un micro ça va tellement vite
donc je profite de votre question pour
dire s'il y a une chose en ce moment
c'est peut-être qu'il y en a un petit
peu moins et c'est ça qui nous a poussé
avec nos experts hier d'attendre un
petit peu avec de prendre quelques jours
de plus pour essayer de bien connaître
ce chiffre-là mais il pourrait être
aussi important que 25 à 30%. alors
c'est pour ça qu'avant de prendre
d'autres décisions très graves au cours
des prochains jours qu'on voulait avoir
ces clarification en parlant justement
de clarification on sait que il y a des
directions de santé publique notamment à
Québec et à Montréal qui recommande aux
gens symptomatiques de d'effectuer des
tests rapides à la maison de ne pas se
présenter dans une clinique de dépistage
alors on a l'impression qu'on ne le sait
plus exactement combien que de codes
covid-19 au Québec comment allez-vous
faire pour comptabiliser ces cas un peu
transparent disparu là du réseau de la
santé puis avoir un portrait réel de la
situation Québec compte tenu des tests
rapides puis tu es directives
j'apprécie votre question parce que
c'était un contexte qui change tellement
vite on n'aurait jamais pensé quelques
semaines qu'on aurait autant de cas par
jour avec au micro en ce moment notre
priorité c'est de vacciner les gens ça
c'est notre priorité puis on a décidé de
faire moins de traçage pour toutes ces
bonnes raisons là et pour répondre à
votre question est-ce qu'on pourra un
jour dans les prochains jours décider
qu'on essaie d'accumuler l'information
ceux qui sont testés eux-mêmes je vous
dirai peut-être mais en ce moment c'est
pas notre priorité notre priorité c'est
de rendre des
rapide disponible le plus rapidement
possible ce qu'on a fait en pharmacie
j'espère qu'on en aura d'autres fédéral
dans les prochains jours puis si on en a
pas d'autres du fédéral mon collègue que
vous voyez ici avec moi monsieur Paris
travaille très fort pour en obtenir
d'autres en ce moment notre priorité
c'est que les gens se fassent dépister
puis on essayera d'avoir des
statistiques de pouvoir communiquer avec
ces gens-là trouver une façon de
communiquer avec ceux qui n'ont pas été
dans un centre de dépistage pour essayer
d'avoir les meilleures statistiques
possible mais en ce moment on est en
train d'essayer de regarder comme on
peut le faire merci
Anne-Marie Provost le devoir concernant
cette nouvelle maison de permettre aux
employés positifs de continent à
travailler il y a pas un risque de
contaminer d'autres travailleurs sur les
lieux de travail qui ont pas testé
positif un risque de contaminer des
patients qui sont vulnérables ou des
gens vulnérables parce que c'est des
minutes de travail qui peuvent être
assez fluides donc il y a pas ce
risque-là qui existe tout à l'heure
madame que c'est une question de gestion
du risque si on avait dans le choix on
le ferait pas soyons très clair qu'on
fait pas ça par gaieté de cœur par
contre les conditions dans lesquelles on
le fait puis j'aimerais peut-être
demander à docteur arudote compléter ma
réponse mais je vais vous dire deux
choses
des gens qui travaillent en ce moment
dans le réseau de la santé c'est un peu
comme tous les cas que vous connaissez
parce qu'on en connaît tous là des gens
qui particulièrement ceux qui sont
asymptomatique en ce moment il y en a
beaucoup et ce qu'on dit c'est que il y
a dans le réseau de santé maintenant des
mesures de protection de contrôle des
infections qui étaient pas en place même
à la première vague on sait que ça c'est
la plus grande différence la deuxième
différence et je l'ai dit nous
travailleurs de la santé sont vaccinés à
98 % de doses
98 %. alors à ce moment-là le risque
comprend c'est un risque qui est
contrôlé on sait que ces gens-là sont
vaccinés et on sait que ces gens-là
s'ils sont positifs serait beaucoup
moins contagieux puis en plus qui ont
les bonnes mesures de masques il y a eu
des demandes qui nous ont été faits pour
des mesures de protection de contrôle
additionnels des EPI additionnels on va
tout respecter les recommandations de la
CNS donc on le fait pas pariété de car
mais on le fait dans un environnement
contrôlé
si vous me permettez à monsieur le
ministre je vais ajouter un élément faut
comprendre qu'actuellement avec le
terrain au niveau transmission aussi
dans la communauté que certains
travailleurs de la santé peuvent
l'attraper la commune et quand on les
retourne en milieu de soins on les
retourne dans les ondes ou on le regarde
chacune des situations que cette
situation on le retourne dans les
endroits où il peut pas déjà infecté il
traverse la santé effectué on s'assure
qui porte les EPI comme le dit le
ministre puis aussi on s'assure qu'ils
disent pas avec d'autres employés parce
que c'était là souvent ta contamination
je faisais non pas lors du milieu de
soins je veux juste vous dire que dans
le fond oui effectivement dans un monde
idéal on rentre pas des personnes
malades dans un milieu mais en même
temps je vais vous juste vous dire le
milieu les gens ont besoin de soin je
sais pas si vous comprenez moi si
j'étais au soin intensif que j'ai besoin
d'un cardiologue comme tel je préfère un
cardiologue qui va être infecté à la
covid-19 peu symptomatique après cette
période est plus contagieuse va piquer
de jeu il va s'occuper de mon cœur parce
que mon risque de mourir du cœur est
plus important c'est là qu'on est en
termes de gestion du risque je trouve
que c'est important que vous compreniez
là c'est que d'autres maladies que la
covid-19 et puis il faut s'occuper de
nos patients qui ont besoin de soins
sinon par rapport à la troisième dose on
sent que à ce moment-ci il y a peut-être
un peu plus de confusion en tout cas du
côté des Québécois sur qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire et tout ça parce que les
choses déboulent rapidement est-ce que
vous sentez que ça va être plus
difficile de mobiliser les Québécois
cette fois-ci que lorsqu'on injectait
les deux premières doses
je vais répondre la première partie que
je vais demander à mon collègue sur
Paris de compléter écoutez pour moi là
s'il y a des gens qui qui avaient encore
un doute que la troisième dose est
importante je pense que voir le nombre
de 12013000 puis peut-être demain 15000
cas là et je pense que la troisième dose
pour moi c'est une évidence il y a des
pays en ce moment qui s'arrachent les
vaccins pour être capable de faire une
première dose et nous on est chanceux
d'avoir accès au troisième dos alors sur
ce point là je pense que malheureusement
la situation avec un micro qui fait
passer décide pour ceux qui ont une
deuxième dose jusqu'à maintenant je
rappelle la statistique quand on avait
deux doses dans un monde qui est pas si
loin quand on avait le delta on avait
une protection de 75 80 85 %
cette protection là malheureusement bien
baisser à 30 % avec au micro alors oui
c'est une bonne chose d'avoir les deux
doses mais pour ceux qui ont déjà rendu
à la troisième passer à la troisième
parce que vous allez rattraper le niveau
de protection que vous aviez avant à peu
près avec le delta donc pour moi c'est
même pas nous c'est même pas une
question c'est une évidence même tous
nos experts de 10 maintenant ce que je
voudrais que Daniel vous dise c'est
comment on est capable de vacciner et ça
c'est notre chance qu'on a parce qu'on
le prouvé alors peut-être que Daniel
pourrait vous donner quelques
statistiques de ce qu'on peut faire
bonjour à tous Pour répondre sur
l'engouement de la troisième dose
seulement hier c'est plus de 270 000
vaccins là excusez-moi un rendez-vous
pour une dose de vaccin qui a été prise
et qu'on la voit l'engouement de la
population et nous on a demandé toutes
les établissements de santé service
sociaux du Québec d'ouvrir des
rendez-vous justement pour bien pour
bien accueillir les gens avec les
nouveaux propriétaires qu'on a annoncé
aujourd'hui et la population générale et
Monsieur Dubé je pense émotionnel parce
qu'on a Lucien on va avoir un gros mois
de janvier
la grande majorité des Québécois on se
rappelle
merci Damien
Martel de la presse on sait que le
manque des personnels touche aussi les
laboratoires de tébistage et je me
demandais comment vous allez vous
assurer que la capacité dépistage soit
maintenue
c'est pour ça tout à l'heure que je les
ai remercié entre notre personnel de
laboratoire parce que moi je comprends
pas comment on a réussi à faire jusqu'à
plus de 50 000 analyses au cours des des
derniers jours ce qui était ce qui est
un record parmi
des maximum qu'on croyait avoir atteint
alors jusqu'à maintenant ça a pas été un
enjeu je pense que c'est
je le répète les gens qui vont se faire
vacciner au centre de dépistage devrait
des gens qui qui ont des cas qui sont
positifs on pense qu'avec ce qu'on a mis
en place avec les tests rapides on peut
diminuer la chalandage puis quand même
permettre l'isolement déjà qui ont des
symptômes et je vous le dis je remercie
tout le monde que dans cette moment-là
très difficile tout notre personnel fait
un effort incroyable puis c'est pour ça
que je le répète faut les appuyer il
faut trouver une façon de les appuyer
puis minimiser nos contacts
puis à propos de la vaccination selon
les données la vaccination chez les 5
ans demeure faible à Montréal que
comptez-vous faire pour encourager
davantage la vaccination dans ce groupe
d'orge là moi je vous trouve dur quand
vous dites que c'est faible parce que
je vois un sourire Daniel parce que je
pense que beaucoup de on est rendu je
vais le laisser parler Daniel 58%
c'est jusqu'à maintenant alors que
l'école est terminée mais peut-être je
vais laisser monsieur Paris répondre
au Québec qui est déjà devenu en
première dose on sait aussi que c'est
des le système scolaire a été également
affecté justement au niveau au niveau
des cas positifs donc n'irons pas
chercher une première dose donc on voit
quand même les calculer ces gens-là sont
quand même considérés mais on sera là
pour leur deuxième dose et pour répondre
à votre question ce qu'on va faire mais
on va faire ce qu'on a fait au printemps
dernier
on va rester ouvert on va continuer de
bien expliquer les bienfaits de la
vaccination de nos jeunes et nous on a
de nos adolescents ça avait pris
quelques signes supplémentaires
exactement les mêmes résultats avec ce
groupe
je pense que j'inviterais merci Daniel
puis j'ai inviterai des parents qui vont
chercher leur troisième dose d'en
profiter pour amener leurs enfants avec
eux je pense que il y a peut-être moins
de choses à faire durant le temps des
fêtes en ce moment alors peut-être que
ce serait une belle activité d'aller au
centre de vaccination
je vais revenir sur les tests rapides le
ministre fédéral de la Santé disait
qu'en date du 23 décembre le Québec en
avait reçu 9.4 millions et que au 31
décembre la province en Europe 11.2
c'est même un peu plus que ce que vous
aviez demandé
cependant dans les pharmacies des
citoyens les cherche ces tests là ils
sont où les tests est-ce qu'on voit
est-ce que les gens vont pouvoir avoir
leur petite boîte de cinq tests
rapidement
moi je peux vous dire c'est que depuis
le mois de décembre
au niveau des services de garde et au
niveau de nos écoles primaires et plus
de 4.5 millions au niveau des pharmacies
et qui ont effectivement compris preneur
et
de voir ça peut-être à la
responsabilités
j'ai attendu un message pour voir la
Fiat de nos prochaines livraisons on en
a besoin de mis en place le système de
distribution avec nos formations
et ce sera distribué pour les Québécois
et encore là nous
on ne donne certains chiffres pour le
mois de pour le mois de janvier et
vraiment de février mais un des montants
si le 31 décembre
toujours en attente mais le système
est en place garantir lorsque les
intéresse
allez-y pour votre succession ensuite on
va passer au journaliste en français en
ligne est-ce que vous avez évalué
monsieur Dubé en permettant le retour
des travailleurs positifs en faisant la
gestion du risque sur l'exemple
d'aujourd'hui où vous parlez de 8000
combien pourraient revenir quelle
attitude ça vous donne
avant d'être confronté à une un brie de
service ou un délestage
les calculs qu'on fait tous les jours
comme je vous dis en ce moment on est
tout près de 8000 puis je pense que si
la tendance continue on va se rapprocher
du 10000 personnes qui vont être absents
pour pour la commune alors c'est sûr que
la situation que je le répète là c'est
pas du mur à mesure qu'on va faire on va
s'ajuster par les régions c'est ce qu'on
a demandé à nous à nous PDG puis aux
responsables de bien trouver la façon de
minimiser l'impact mais c'est sûr que
c'est c'est notre corps région Paris
Région hôpital par hôpital
CHSLD tout y passe en ce moment pour
être sûr qu'on minimise l'impact d'une
telle mesure mais encore une fois on a
vécu dans la première vague des brides
services qui ont occasionné à des gens
de pas avoir plus particulièrement en
CHSLD de pas avoir de service on veut
pas revivre et c'est pour ça que malgré
le choix difficile qu'on fait on pense
que c'est le meilleur choix à faire
nous allons maintenant poursuivre avec
la période de questions avec les
journalistes en virtuel donc je vous
invite à lever la main sur la plateforme
zone
oui bonjour Est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui
bonjour Alors moi j'ai pu constater que
il est de plus en plus difficile de
trouver des rendez-vous pour se faire
dépister on a certains endroits où faut
attendre jusqu'à 5 janvier à moins de
changer de région à Montréal il y a
plusieurs centres qui n'ont carrément
plus de disponibilités alors qu'est-ce
que vous comptez faire pour pour régler
cette situation là
oui je peux je peux m'avancer sur
certains éléments mais effectivement au
centre de dépistage sont occupés sont
incapacité maximum on avait déjà une
capacités fixe au niveau de nos
laboratoires
par jour et là ça nous amène vraiment
parce que la population
pour les centres de dépistage de venir
qu'on est pour deux mais encore là
de prendre ses précautions de base et en
même temps pour ceux qui ont la chance
d'avoir des tests rapides de bien les
utiliser dans ces circonstances là mais
on est rendu à cette auto se
responsabiliser
et au niveau de l'hôpital on va
continuer de fabriquer
à avoir à maximiser la capacité
parfait merci pour la deuxième question
justement les tests de dépistage rapide
bon évidemment on sait que ceci ne sont
pas comptabilisés dans les données
quotidiennes ce qui manque donc pas
l'ampleur de la vague d'infection pas
dans la province est-ce que vous pensez
créer une plateforme pour que les
Québécois puissent inscrire leurs
résultats histoire qu'on est peut-être
une meilleure idée de la situation et si
vous pourquoi ça pas été plutôt
maintenant qu'on les utilise
on a beaucoup de gens qui sont
occupés à autre chose en ce moment je
vais le dire comme ça parce que on est
vraiment en guerre pour vacciner le plus
grand nombre de personnes de toutes les
façons mais si ça s'avère moi j'ai des
rencontres encore avec la soumise cet
après-midi pour discuter de la pratique
habilité de de ça avec avec Monsieur
Paris puis si on pense que c'est la
bonne chose à faire pour avoir de
meilleurs statistiques qu'on le fera
mais toutes sortes d'un jeu
opérationnels parce que là à ce
moment-là faut se fier aux gens à ce
qu'on va avoir d'information qui qui est
à propos faire le match avec les gens
qui ont déjà eu une deuxième dose il y a
toutes sortes de considérations mais je
vous répondrai
on le regarde mais il y a peut-être
d'autres priorités en ce moment avec
tout ce qu'on vient de discuter
aujourd'hui c'est le ministre qui vous
me permettez je voudrais aussi ajouter
le fait que toutes les juridictions qui
ont introduit les tests je voudrais
rapide ont eu une perte de formation
c'est un phénomène partout à travers le
monde là ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi
on vous l'avait dit que notre indicateur
principal va être les hospites les soins
intensifs
c'est agréable d'avoir le bon chiffre de
façon le chemin le chiffre n'est jamais
le vrai nom parce que quand on a pas
beaucoup de capacités de dépistage on a
des pistes qu'une seule partie quand on
en a beaucoup beaucoup on va avoir des
plus gros chiffres puis on sait qu'on
peut même pas comparer les chiffres d'un
pays à d'autres à cause notamment par
rapport au cas notamment à cause de ces
variations là de dépistage donc je veux
pas dire qu'il faut pas essayer de faire
un effort pour avoir le meilleur
portrait mais moi nettement ce qui
m'importe actuellement là oui le nombre
de cas parce que ça vous permet de dire
que ça se transmet beaucoup et puis je
pense que déjà à 12000 fois par jour si
je peux un message à dire au Québécois
si vous voulez pas l'attraper parce
qu'il est excessivement virulent
diminuer vos contacts si vous n'avez pas
besoin de sortir ne sortez pas faites
pas des rassemblements industrent pas
nécessaire que ce soit 12000 ou 20 000
c'est le même message nous ce qui est
très important par contre c'est pas
l'impact des hospites les soins
intensifs je veux pas minimiser le
chiffre mais je veux juste que vous
compreniez pour une prise de décision et
je préfère que les gens soient vaccinés
des 60 ans et plus et la population à
travers la santé à faire de la
vaccination de ces accumuler des
statistiques un commentaire là quand
même mais oubliez pas on regarde les
hospites
Frédéric Lacroix couture La Presse
Canadienne
oui bonjour monsieur Duby vous avez
parlé plutôt de la possibilité d'ajouter
des mesures supplémentaires si
nécessaire qu'elle pourrait être ces
mesures supplémentaires est-ce que le
couvre-feu est toujours dans les plans
une possibilité à ce moment-là
écoutez c'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
fait tous les jours c'est de considérer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus je
rappelle que l'équipe québécois dans un
contexte mondial sont ceux qui ont le
plus de mesures en ce moment
et on a regardé on a fait une veille
internationale depuis des semaines de ce
qui se passe dans les pays européens
incluant incluant le couvre-feu ou
différentes versions du couvre-feu mais
moi j'aimerais en profiter de votre
question pour vous donner une
statistique qui a énormément beaucoup
d'impact sur nous puis sur nos experts
en ce moment si vous prenez
juste il y a quelques semaines la
proportion des vaccinés versus les non
vaccinés qui rentraient à l'hôpital
était d'à peu près
1 pour 3 c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
beaucoup il y avait des vaccinés mais la
grande majorité étant donné qu'on avait
6 millions de Québécois qui était double
dessiner qui malheureusement pouvait
contracter la maladie je vous donnerai
l'inverse le changement qui est arrivé
avec au micro-ondes dans les derniers
jours prenez juste la journée d'hier
docteur aruda vient de dire qu'on a eu
12000 ko hier 12000 codes déclarés sur
12000 cas déclarés hier il y en a
environ 8000 qui était non vacciné
ça ça veut dire que c'est des gens qui
rentrent à l'hôpital c'est des gens qui
vont aller aux soins intensifs alors
pour moi sur quelque chose à se rappeler
qui est en train d'arriver puis c'est
pour ça que je l'ai dit tantôt dans mon
allocution si la tendance se maintient
tous les vaccins tous les non vaccinés
au cours des prochains mois bon soit se
faire vacciner ce qui serait la bonne
chose à faire ou vont contracter la
maladie alors je le rappelle des
chiffres sont têtus malheureusement
c'est ça qui est en train d'arriver ici
la compte vous est dit l'autre fois
qu'il y avait plus les 10 souvent qui
avait à peu près 600 000 personnes qui
étaient non vaccinées au rythme
d'aujourd'hui et des derniers jours
dans moins 3 mois tout des normes
vaccinés vont avoir contracté la maladie
c'est à eux de décider de quel côté ils
veulent se trouver
et certains suggèrent de repousser le
retour en classe pour les écoles
primaires et secondaires et d'ici pour
l'enseignement supérieur est-ce que
c'est une option une mesure que vous
envisagez aussi à ce moment tout est
tout est sur la table mais sur on a
toujours gardé la question des écoles
ouvertes le plus longtemps possible pour
une foule de rêve pas c'est un choix de
société qu'on a fait mais c'est sûr
qu'on va regarder comment évoluer les
choses mais pour le moment on a parlé du
10 janvier puis j'aimerais qu'on reste
avec ce cette date là en tête pour le
moment
ça va passer à Pascal gaccès de du
journal Métro
bonjour monsieur
c'est selon les derniers chiffres donc
de donner de santé Québec il y a
actuellement 587 hospitalisation et en
soins intensifs il y en a 115 alors on
se rapproche petit à petit donc des
capacités réelles qui sont mentionnées
sur Saint-Étienne Québec qui disent 825
personnes hospitalisées hors soins
intensifs et 210 en soins intensifs vu
qu'on se rapproche petit à petit est-ce
qu'il y a quand même une façon de
rassurer les populations sur la capacité
hospitalière du Québec monsieur Dubé
mais vous avez vu
bien sûr pour la question vous avez vu
il y a deux semaines qu'on a le jeudi de
deux semaines c'était moi pas au jour
exact mais on augmentait la capacité
d'hospitalisation des lits covid en
faisant du délestage on est passé en
gros du niveau 2 de délestage au niveau
3 c'est ce qui nous a permis de passer
d'à peu près 600 litres à 810 pour les
hospitalisations
mais je le répète c'est là qu'on ne veut
pas aller en ce moment d'aller au niveau
4 qui nous permettrait de me faire que
des soins intensifs alors c'est pour ça
qu'on demande étant donné le nombre de
personnels qui est absent ou qui sera
absent qu'on a annoncé les mesures
d'aujourd'hui donc ça c'est pour ce
qu'on va demander aux personnel ce qu'on
demande au Québec puis encore une fois
je le répète c'est d'être capable de
limiter les contacts les Québécois n'ont
très très bien fait puis même durant les
fêtes on a vu la baisse du niveau des
contacts avec les nouvelles mesures
qu'on a fait mais je le rappelle s'il y
a un groupe qui peut nous aider en ce
moment c'est des non vaccinés
justement je vais vous continuez sur ce
sujet les non vaccinés je sais que
Monsieur ratio aruda n'impact faire des
comparaisons avec d'autres zones du
monde mais par exemple l'Autriche a mis
en place l'obligation vaccinale
l'Allemagne est en train de l'envisager
et je voulais simplement savoir au
Québec ben où est-ce qu'on est se débat
est-ce que c'est envisagé c'est sur la
table ou à côté de la table
écoutez il faut comprendre que tout est
sur la table actuellement
c'est sûr que on a toujours pensé que
c'est toujours mieux de convaincre les
gens mais tout dépendamment de la menace
c'est ce que ça peut représenter il peut
y avoir des décisions qui sont prises
autres
chez culturellement selon les pays c'est
différent il y a certains pays je
voudrais plus du tatoriau qui l'ont
imposer à l'ensemble la société on a vu
qu'on a essayé de le faire notamment
aussi du côté des travailleurs de la
santé ça pas toujours été évident puis
on a quand même augmenté de façon
significative la couverture vaccinale je
pense que c'est une chose à regarder ce
n'est pas notre première mesure bien
entendu il y a différents enjeux
associés à ça mais je ne ferme pas la
porte à rien vous avez un covid-19 il y
en a faire faut apprendre c'est qu'il
faut pas penser et je l'ai dit dès le
premier point de presse mais j'aurais
jamais pensé que c'était autant ça que
aujourd'hui peut être différent demain
et je peux vous dire que l'eau micron ça
n'éteint de ceux qui nous amènent à nous
acheter très rapidement
nous sommes maintenant rendus à la
période de questions pour les
journalistes en anglais donc pour ce
président dans la salle
micro un c'est à vous
[Musique]
looks
Daniel eternez looking
CHSLD Dats morning